sion quant à la comédie française et
bien c'est jean le poulain qui va en
prendre la direction
anne rongère la nomination d'un
administrateur c'est un peu comme
l'élection de miss france où la nuit des
césar l'heureuse élue se doit d'être à
la fois ravis et surpris jean le poulain
respecte la tradition
avez vous des projets précis n'ont
absolument aucun projet précis
étant donnée la soudaineté évidemment de
cette nomination mais je pense que c'est
avec le comité avec les acteurs de la
comédie-française que nous établirons un
programme qui devient maintenant assez
choquant alors vous n'avez pas tout à
fait répondu à ma question je vous
demandais quelles sont les qualités
humaines discrétion tact volonté dont il
faut faire preuve à ce poste je crois
qu'ils abordent puissance de travail
considérable beaucoup de courage de
patience et surtout surtout une grande
tolérance tolérance le grand mot est
lâché dans cette maison parfois victimes
de la guerre des clans à l'image de son
appartement qui a tout d'un petit
théâtre
le nouvel administrateur est un homme de
tradition un homme du sérail depuis six
ans
alors doit-on voir dans sa nomination un
retour à une politique artistique plus
prudente après le passage de jean pierre
vincent le plus jeune administrateur qui
avait voulu réveiller la vieille dame
tricentenaire vous avez l'air frais
permettez moi de vous le dire ça vient
pas toujours de l'extérieur suffit de
faire un courant d'air et puis leurs
frais ils arrivent
l'administrateur et tout puissant c'est
lui qui engageait nouveaux sociétaires
lui qui décide seul
la programmation des pièces et leur
distribution
la tradition veut que son arrivée fasse
grincer quelques dents c'est le cas ce
soir les comédiens français sont en
assemblée générale c'est peut-être aussi
la loi du genre
difficile de faire l'unanimité au pays
des orias et des curiaces